[Musique]
c'est bizarre qui vivent seules ils sont
pas sécurité c'est celui ci on passe
dans l'argent camilla est morte il ya
quelqu'un d'autre dans la maison par
pitié ne descendez pas c'est quoi ça
l'assise entame arrêter de parler et de
marché elle m'a demandé pourquoi dieu le
punisse et tamara n'est ni malade ni
folle
tant qu'il est encore tôt camara
tamara
je n'ai jamais vu une possession aussi
puissante délivre nous du mal un des
livres nous de s'attendre ce n'est que
le début et au ya quelqu'un mon dieu
qu'il n'est pas seul
ils sont des centaines
telefonica s'attend
[Applaudissements]
alors surface à ce témoin camara